>> Greg: HAPPY TUESDAY,
EVERYONE.
I HAVE TO SAY, THIS IS THE
BEST-LOOKING AUDIENCE WE HAVE
HAD SO FAR.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YEAH.
YUMMY.
THERE'S MORE 10s THAN IN THE
CHRISTMAS CARDS I GIVE MY STAFF.
THEY SMILE SO MUCH WHEN THEY
OPEN IT.
BUT YOU PEOPLE AT HOME CAN'T SEE
THIS AUDIENCE BUT TRUST ME IT'S
LIKE LOOKING AT A SEA OF LATER
KUDLOWS.
THE ONLY MAN WHO CAN MAKE SOCK
GUARDERS SEXY.
SPEAKING MUCH RICH PEOPLE CHECK
IN ON ELON MUSK WHO MAY BE THE
BEST TWEETER SINCE TRUMP.
IT BEGAN SUNDAY WITH HIM SAYING
TWITTER BEING SUPER SLOW WHEN A
TWITTER JEERED CALLED OUT THE
MUSK TWEET ADDING QUOTE I SPENT
SIX YEARS WORKING ON TWITTER AND
CAN SAY THIS IS WRONG.
WHEN SOMEONE POINTED OUT YOU
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T CALL OUT YOUR
BOSS PUBLICLY HE KEPT GOING AND
THAT'S WHEN MUSK HIT BACK, HE'S
FIRED.
NOW, IF YOU DON'T FIND THAT
HILARIOUS, THEN YOU'RE NOT MY
FRIEND AND YOU'VE NEVER FIRED
ANYONE WHO REALLY DESERVES IT.
IT'S WHY I HAD A TRAP DOOR
INSTALLED IN MY OFFICE AND HIRED
A CONTRACTOR WHO CAN KEEP A
SECRET.
BUT IF I TWEETED ABOUT HOW I RUN
THIS SHOW, I'D PROBABLY BE
ARRESTED POSSIBLY FOR MURDER.
IF YOU GUYS HAD ANY IDEA WHAT I
SPENT ON BLEACH AND ROPE ALONE
LAST MONTH.
AND THAT'S JUST ON THE INTERNS
WHO MADE EYE CONTACT.
BUT FOR MUSK, IT ONLY GETS
BETTER.
ON SUNDAY HE ANNOUNCED PLANS TO
END FREE LUNCHES AT TWITTER
HEADQUARTERS SAYING THE MEALS
COST THE COMPANY 13 MILLION
BUCKS A YEAR.
THAT'S STILL $2 MILLION LESS
THAN THE VIEW SPENDS ON FEEDING
JOY BAHAR.
I DON'T LIKE JOY.
>> Harris: WHERE DID YOU GET
THAT PICTURE?
>> Greg: I HAVE THEM ALL AT
HOME.
THE PROBLEM WAS NO ONE WAS
COMING TO THE OFFICE AND THAT
WAS DRIVING UP THE COST.
THEY WERE THROWING FOOD AWAY
LIKE IT HAD BEEN COOKED BY KAT.
BUT MUSK MAKING A SOUND BUSINESS
CALL MADE HIM EVEN MORE EVIL.
ONE DEMOCRAT ACTIVIST SAID HE
FIRED THREE-FOURTHS OF THE
EMPLOYEES NOW HE'S PLANNING TO
STAR HAVE THE REST OF THEM.
YEAH, THEY'RE ALL GOING TO DIE
BECAUSE THEIR BOSSES WON'T COVER
THEIR SUSHI.
WHAT LAME 0S.
YOU WANT A FREE LUNCH BROWN BAG
IT YOU LOSERS.
THAT'S WHAT MY STAFF DOES.
IT'S GREAT I JUST TAKE A BITE
FROM EACH ONE OF THEIR
SANDWICHES.
I HAVEN'T BOUGHT A LUNCH IN
YEARS.
THEY ALL GOT HEPATITIS.
AND WHAT DOES ELON KNOW ABOUT
BUSINESS ANYWAY?
HE'S JUST THE WORLD'S RICHEST
MAN UNLIKE SOME UNEMPLOYED 32
YEAR OLD ACTIVIST MOANING ON
TWITTER ABOUT FOOD.
BOTTOM LINE IT'S GREAT WATCHING
SOMEONE RUN A COMPANY WITH FULL
TRANSPARENCY.
HE DOES EVERYTHING WITH THE DOOR
OPEN.
LIKE WHEN DOOCY USES THE
BATHROOM ON THE PLANE.
EVEN MORE MUSK IS WILLING TO ASK
SEEMINGLY OBVIOUS QUESTIONS THAT
NO ONE EVER HAD THE GUTS TO ASK.
DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF ANYONE?
YEAH.
WHEN TRUMP WAS IN CHARGE, HE
WOULD QUESTION EVERYTHING FROM
TRADE WITH CHINA TO THE WATER
PRESSURE OF SHOWERS.
>> BUT HOW ABOUT THE SHOWER?
YOU GO INTO A SHOWER, AND I HAVE
THIS BEAUTIFUL HEAD OF HAIR.
YOU TURN ON THE WATER, DRIP,
DRIP, DRIP.
AND THE WORRY COMES DRIPPING
OUT.
JUST DRIPPING OUT VERY QUIETLY.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU JUST STAND THERE LONGER, YOU
TAKE A SHOWER LONGER.
BECAUSE MY HAIR, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU, BUT IT HAS TO BE
PERFECT.
>> Greg: HE SOUNDS LIKE JOE
TALKING ABOUT TAKING A LEAK.
OH.
BUT NO WONDER MUSK HAS TAKEN
TRUMP'S PLACE AT THE LEFT'S TOP
TARGET.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS MUSK
CAN'T RUN FOR PRESIDENT WHICH IS
PROBABLY A GOOD THING FOR THE
DEMS BECAUSE HE WOULD PROBABLY
WIN.
AND SPEAKING OF THE DEMS, ODDLY
THEY'RE OBSESSED WITH BRINGING
MUSK DOWN BUT THEY DON'T SEEM TO
CARE ABOUT THE BITCOIN BANDIT
SAM BANKMAN FRIED THE FOUNDER OF
THE CRYPTO EXCHANGE CALLED FTX
RESIGNED WHEN HIS COMPANY WENT
BELLY UP QUICKER THAN A FIVE
YEAR OLD'S GOLD FISH.
SO WHY NO CONCERN OVER HIM?
WHY HAVEN'T YOU HEARD OF HIM
UNTIL NOW?
HE WAS BIDEN'S SECOND BIGGEST
DONOR AND PUMPED MILLIONS INTO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO IMAGINE THAT COINCIDENCE.
BUT IT TURNS OUT HE USED HIS
CRYPTO COMPANY TO BORROW REAL
DOLLARS THAT HE COULDN'T PAY
BACK.
REUTERS REPORTED BETWEEN ONE AND
$2 BILLION OF CUSTOMER IF YOU
UNDERSTAND ARE GONE.
BUT NOT BEFORE THE DEMS SPENT 40
MILLION OF HIS MONEY JUST IN
TIME FOR THE MIDTERMS.
YEAH, THE TIMING IS IMPECCABLE
KIND OF LIKE BAN IRK A STORY ON
THE BIDEN FAMILY JUST BEFORE THE
2020 ELECTION.
I'M SENSING A PATTERN.
SO NOW HIS COMPANY IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR A SCAM THAT
WOULD MAKE BURN YES MAY KOCH
LOOK LIKE A MEDIA SCOUT.
WHERE IS THE MEDIA.
THEY SUSPENDED THEIR SKEPTICISM
WHEN IT BECAME SO OBVIOUS THIS
GUY'S A CLOWN.
>> SAM IS NOT THE TRADITIONAL
BILLIONAIRE BECAUSE HE BELIEVES
IN THE CONCEPT OF EARN TO GIVE.
>> EARNING TO GIVE IS THINKING
ABOUT WHICH CAUSES WHICH
CHARITIES SAVE THE MOST LIVES
PER DOLLAR.
>> NEXT YEAR HE'S PLANNING TO
DONATE $500 MILLION A YEAR AND
NEXT DECADE, HE WILL PROBABLY
GIVE AWAY MORE THAN $10 BILLION.
AND HE IS FUNDING EVERYTHING YOU
CAN THINK OF.
GLOBAL WARMING.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE TO TACKLE
TOGETHER AS A WORLD.
>> COVID-19 PREPAREDNESS.
>> WE HAVE TO BE READY FOR THE
NEXT PANDEMIC.
>> AND, OF COURSE, ANIMAL
WELFARE.
>> ANIMALS DESERVE TO LIVE JUST
LIKE WE DO.
IT'S ALSO WHY I'M VEGAN.
>> DUDE, IF YOU'RE THAT RICH,
BUY A BRA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: MY GOD.
TERRIBLE.
>> WOW.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT BODY SHAMING,
I'M JUST CONCERNED.
NOW, IF YOU BELIEVE ANYTHING
THAT FRUIT CAKE SAYS, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD LOSE ALL YOUR MONEY.
BUT HE TRICKED THEM ALL WITH A
RIGHT VERB TIE SIGNALS, THE
RIGHT LEFT WING CAUSES AND ALL
THE RIGHT CASH.
SO WILL THE MEDIA HAVE ANY
INTEREST IN DIGGING FURTHER INTO
A STORY FILLED WITH SIX, DRUGS
AND CORRUPTION?
WELL, MAYBE THEY SHOULD READ
HARRIS FAULKNER'S NEW BOOK.
>> Harris: GREG.
IT'S A BOOK ABOUT PRAYER.
>> Greg: WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
BUT WHO AM I KIDDING?
THE MEDIA HAS ABOUT AS MUCH
CHANCE OF COVERING THAT STORY AS
A BELLY SHIRT DOES JERRY
NADLER'S NAVAL.
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE'S SOBRIETY SHE FILLS IN FOR
THE SUN WHEN IT TAKES A DAY OFF.
HOST OF THE FAULKNER FOCUS AND
AUTHOR OF THE GREAT NEW BOOK
FAITH STILL MOVES MOUNTAINS,
HARRIS FAULKNER
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HE'S AN INSPIRATION TO
MILLIONS OF MEN WHO ALSO CUT
THEIR OWN HAIR.
THE COMEDIAN BEHIND TERRORIZING
TELEMARKETERS SEVEN JIM
FLORENTIN:  AND SHE'S ALWAYS
BEEN DRIVEN TO THE PSYCH WARD.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HE EATS SOUP OUT OF THE
ASTRO DOME, MY MASSIVE SIDE KICK
AND THE NEW NWA WORLD HEAVY
WEIGHT CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HARRIS, FIRST OF ALL I
GOT YOUR BOOK FAITH STILL MOVES
MOUNTAINS, I DO AS I ALWAYS DO I
LOOK UNDER THE INDEX UNDER G AND
THERE'S ONLY ONE ENTITY UNDER G
AND IT'S NOT GUTFELD, IT'S GOD.
I, YOU KNOW, IF I'M GOING TO BE
MUSCLED OUT OF THE INDEX, I'M
GLAD IT WAS GOD AND NOT LIKE, I
DON'T KNOW, GARY --.
>> Tyrus: GERALDO
>> Greg: GERALDO.
>> Tyrus: THANK YOU.
>> Harris: IT'S A BOOK ABOUT
FAITH.
SO THE LORD OR GOD GETS FIRST
CREDIT.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'RE
CLAPPING, YOU'RE ALL GOING TO
HELL.
.
>> Harris: WELL, YOU KNOW WHO WE
ARE A GOING TO SEE THERE IS
BANKMAN.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
YOU LOOK AT THAT.
WHO WOULD GIVE MONEY TO SOMEBODY
THAT IS BASICALLY SPOUTING THESE
LIKE PLATTITUDE THAT ARE SO
OBVIOUSLY FAKE, YOU KNOW, GLOBAL
WARMING'S A PROBLEM AND I'M A
VEGAN.
>> Harris: SO I'M LESS CONCERNED
ABOUT LIKE JUST ORDINARY FOLK.
I WANT TO KNOW THE MONEY THAT
FLOWED TO DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Harris: WE NEED TO KNOW -- WE
TALK ABOUT DARK MONEY AND WE
DON'T FIND OUT ABOUT THIS GUY
UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION AND HOW
MUCH HE SWAYED PEOPLE AND YOU
COULD MAKE THE ARGUMENT, BECAUSE
THE NUMBERS MATCH.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Harris: THE 40 MILLION AND
THE 40 MILLION THAT DEMOCRATS
POURED INTO RACES TO LIFT UP THE
FAR RIGHT CANDIDATES THAT THEY
THOUGHT THEY COULD BEAT.
AND, IN THE END, THEY DID.
>> Greg: YEAH, I KNOW, IT
WORKED.
IT WAS A SNEAKY LITTLE STRATEGY
AND I'M A LITTLE JEALOUS THAT
THE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T THINK OF
IT BUT IT'S TRUE.
ALSO FUNNELED IT THROUGH
UKRAINE.
IT'S SO CONFUSING, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT MAKES SENSE ANYMORE.
>> Harris: WE NEED TO KNOW.
>> Greg: YEAH, WE NEED TO KNOW.
JIM DO YOU ENJOY WATCHING PEOPLE
GET FIRED ON TWITTER LIKE I DO?
>> Jim: I LOVE IT MAN.
ELON'S BASICALLY AUDITIONING FOR
THE APPRENTICE THE REBOOT.
HE'S ALREADY GOT THE CATCH
PHRASE YOU'RE FIRED.
BUT HE'S FIRING SO MANY PEOPLE
OVER THERE HE'S GOING TO BE
ANSWERING THE PHONES SOON AT
TWITTER.
LIKE THERE'S NOBODY LEFT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: DO YOU LIKE WHAT HE'S
DOING?
>> Jim: I LOVE WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> Greg: YEAH?
>> Jim: BUT THE EMPLOYEE CAN'T
CALL HIM OUT ON TWITTER.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
HE JUST THOUGHT THAT NOTHING WAS
EVER GOING TO HAPPEN TO HIM.
ONE GOOD THING ABOUT THAT GUY,
HE'LL SAVE EIGHT BUCKS A MONTH
BECAUSE HE'S NOT GETTING A BLUE
CHECK.
THERE'S NO WAY.
HE'S OUT.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
KAT ONCE CALLED ME A BOOMER
>> Kat: I KNEW YOU WERE GOING TO
BRING THAT UP.
WE GOT INTO A HUGE FIGHT BECAUSE
I CALLED HIM A BOOMER ON
TWITTER.
>> Greg: I THINK I BLOCKED YOU
>> Kat: NO YOU DIDN'T THIS IS
WHY I DON'T WANT TO ASSOCIATE
WITH YOU ON TWITTER OR REAL
LIFE.
HE SAID THAT.
AND I WAS LIKE DO I COME TO THE
MEETING TOMORROW?
OR NOT?
>> Greg: THIS IS THE PROBLEM
WITH TWITTER FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME
IS GENERALLY IF I'M ON IT, IT'S
AFTER WORK, IT'S AT NIGHT AND
I'M DRINKING.
SO IT'S LIKE, THERE'S NO
OTHER -- I'M GOING TO GET IN
TROUBLE NO MATTER WHAT.
I'VE TAKEN CONTROL OF IT.
NOW I HAVE THIS EXPERIMENT WHERE
I CAN LOOK AT MY TWITTER FEED
AND YOU CAN'T TELL IF I'VE HAD A
DRINK OR NOT.
THAT'S PROGRESS.
>> Harris: I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
SAY ABOUT THAT
>> Kat: IS IT?
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: BETTER JUST NOT TO
>> Kat: BUT YOU DID IT BY JUST
MAKING YOUR SOBER SELF MORE
UNSNOOINGD EXACTLY.
DO YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
BANKMAN OR MUSK?
>> Kat: EITHER WAY.
I COULD HAVE TALKED SO MUCH
ABOUT HANKMAN BUT YESTERDAY MY
HUSBAND WAS COMING UP TRYING TO
TALK TO ME ABOUT THIS.
AND I WAS LIKE THAT'S BORING
SHUT UP BACHELOR IN PARADISE IS
ON.
THEN I SEE IT ON THE RUN DOWN.
I HAD A FINANCE BRO TO TELL ME
ALL THESE FINANCE THINGS AND I
TOLD HIM TO STOP TALKING.
YOU SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THIS GUY
WASN'T RICH BECAUSE HE'S 28
YEARS OLD AND HE'S STILL THAT
UGLY.
>> Greg: YES.
NICE.
IT'S TRUE.
>> Jim: HAVE YOU EVER SEEN
ANOTHER 20-SOMETHING RICH UGLY
PERSON?
NO, YOU HAVE NOT.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Jim: BECAUSE MONEY SOLVES ANY
COSMETIC ISSUE THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
>> Harris: I WISH THAT WERE
TRUE.
>> Kat: I THINK SO FAR IT IS.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY.
>> Greg: I DON'T BELIEVE HE WAS
ACTUALLY A BILLIONAIRE TYRUS.
DO YOU?
>> Tyrus: NO.
NO, WHAT?
WHAT?
OKAY.
FIRST OF ALL, HIS AD CAMPAIGN
WAS LIKE STEP BROTHERS WITHOUT
THE REALLY GOOD ACTORS.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
STAND IN FRONT OF A REFRIGERATOR
WITH NOTHING BUT CONDIMENTS
SAYING I'M A VEGAN AND YOU DON'T
STAND IN FRONT OF THE OCEAN TO
TALK ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING.
>> Greg: ALSO SAID HE WAS FOR
GLOBAL WARNING.
HE HASN'T EVEN DONE THE
HOMEWORK.
>> Tyrus: WE'RE PUTTING HIM
EVERYWHERE.
THE CAMERA CREW ALONE SHOULD
HAVE LET YOU KNOW MONEY WAS
TIGHT.
THEY HAD ONE CAMERA AND A
MIRROR, LIKE THAT SHOULD HAVE
LET YOU KNOW.
AND YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT YOUR
BOSS IN AN OPEN FORUM.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
TIMES I'VE GRABBED YOUR PHONE
AND BEEN LIKE MR. MURDOCH'S NOT
GOING TO LIKE THAT, NO.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Tyrus: SO IT WASN'T THE FACT
THAT HE WAS FIRED.
IT WAS THE TWEET THAT FOLLOWED
WHERE THE GUY GOES, WELL, I
GUESS I'M FIRED.
YOU GUESSED?
YOU CONTRADICTED YOUR BOSS, HE
TALKED ABOUT YOU IN PAST TENSE.
HE ALREADY -- HE'S FIRED.
HE DIDN'T SAY YOU'RE FIRED.
HE'S FIRED WHICH MEANS PAPERWORK
DONE, EXIT INTERVIEW ALREADY
HAPPENED.
BAD.
SNOWBELT THE BEST THING IS THE
GUY ADMITTING HE FAILED.
HE GOES I WORKED THERE FOR SIX
YEARS AND THIS WAS ALL WRONG.
AND IT'S LIKE WHAT DID YOU DO?
>> Tyrus: WHAT DID ANY OF THEM
DO.
ALL THEY DID WAS SAY NO ONE LIKE
GUTFELD.
THAT'S ALL THEY SAID.
>> Greg: I SAW THAT.
>> Harris: THEY ATE FREE
LUNCHES.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I HAVE A VISION THAT THEY'RE
SNEAKING BACK IN GETTING THE
FOOD AND GOING TO WORK FROM
HOME.
BECAUSE HOW DID THEY NOT NOTICE
THE 13 --.
>> Tyrus: YEAH CAME TO WORK FOR
LUNCH AND WENT BACK HOME.
>> Harris: THEY'RE STILL
SPENDING THE $13 MILLION ON THE
FOOD.
SO EITHER SOMEBODY HAS BE
CONNEDED WITH THE 13 MILLION OR
THEY'RE EATING IT.
>> Tyrus: OR IS IT WHERE THE
WHOLE YOU CAN'T FAT SHAME ME